former President Jimmy Carter says
senator McCain's death does not signal
the end of bipartisanship in Washington
we spoke with President Carter yesterday
at a Habitat for Humanity worksite in
Indiana John McCain also served in the
Navy of course passed away recently what
are your thoughts on his passing
well John McCain's service in the Navy
made me proud his personal heroism has
been proven and I think here's a basic
integrity his commitment to the truth no
matter if it was politically unpopular I
was accepted by him as something that
had to be done so I think that John
McCain was admirable as a naval officer
as a human being and as a member of the
US Senate when you look at the Senate as
it has changed when you were in office
some people are saying that John
McCain's death represents the end of
kind of an era
I wouldn't say that maybe temporarily
but I have confidence in the future of
the United States of America you know
we've placed problems even more than we
have now in the past we've overcome them
mr. Carter's survived his own battle
with brain tumors in 2015 we'll have
more of our interview with President
Carter in our next hour here his vision
for America's future and what motivates
him to continue volunteering with
Habitat for Humanity after nearly 35
years